- Bro.
- What?
- Yeah. [bleep] yeah, bro.
- How awesome is this?
- It's cool.
- [bleep] yeah, it is.
Hit it. Hit it. Hit it. Hit it.
Yeah.
Dude, Synchronize. Synchronize.
Yeah, there it is.
Now we're doing it.
♪ Doing it with my bro
doing it with my bro ♪
♪ I love every second
of doing it with my bro. ♪
- It's... It's pretty awesome.
- Can you believe it?
- Can you just...
- Yo. Yo. Right there, man.
Just give me five, man.
Give me five, bro.
Come on,
that's [bleep] pussy[bleep].
Come on.
- Oh, you're with me now.
- You know...
- You are with me now.
- That's disturbing.
- Keep 'em locked.
Keep 'em locked.
You ain't goin' nowhere.
Give me five.
- Mm-mm.
- Give it back.
- Get your... Get...
Aah!
Oh!
- Dude!
How we gonna break
the world record
if you can't keep it up?